hey guys i'm ryan right and i am jerry
and stuff yep and tonight we're gonna
watch a TV spot of guess what movie a
movie never releases footage ever
oh god this is something that's about
time we got footage from the amazing
spider-man 2 this is like TV spot number
17 movie close number Daisy put the
movie on the internet movie on the
internet what's wrong with you guys
I mean Sony I'm just a little confused
it's like guys chill people will see
your damn movie don't make me hate this
it's too much Here I am there's more
footage it's like leave something at
least a like I can kind of tell how this
movie's going to possibly play out till
the very end when we finally find out if
Gwen Stacy dies or not in this film
that's the only thing I feel like hasn't
been told like it's like guys I get it
it's a big battle and Harry Osborn and
Electra it's like Lincoln it surprises
please I would like at least one
surprise during this whole movie but
we're gonna watch it today anyway that's
what happens man I always [ __ ] about
[ __ ] how they're releasing so much
stuff and then I'm like who knew movie
clip and then here we are and I was like
why not bring Jerry along for my awesome
journey to balance out the enthusiam
here we go guys TV spot called promise
let's do this what what do you think his
promise is gonna be what great power
comes great responsibility
no his promise is gonna be that there's
gonna be another trailer now that's the
promise that's the promise
they're touching on the fact that go in
my diet whoa
whoa is the first time they've shown him
not making that smile cuz every other
trailer they showed Dane DeHaan and he's
always doing that same smile and they're
always looping dialogue into it isn't
that the question of the day yeah he's
got that same [ __ ] smile with those
piercing blue eyes that was a cool clip
yes what more can you say
the footage still looks awesome yep
these are my new thoughts on the video
it looks cool I'm pretty incredible I
guess my favorite thing about it is that
it is very brief
they just keep solidifying like no trust
us guys this is awesome this is awesome
so when I watch a travel like whoa then
I'm done like yeah it still looks
awesome yeah this makes me worried now
though because it seems like they're
they're trying so hard to be like no no
no no it's awesome though it's just so
awesome you know look at this now it's a
[ __ ] awesome so now I'm like worried
like is something the matter I get it if
it was like a mystery kind of story or
whatever but it's not that we're not
playing clue here it's like you're
giving away all the best [ __ ] you're
giving away all the money shots yeah
exactly I'm sure there'll be plenty more
of course but [ __ ] it that was fun Oh
real quick hey Jerry real quick if
you're new to the channel subscribe
please do that subscribe you look
significantly shorter than me in the
frame I know because I'm hunting okay
cuz we're about the same height you
might be even taller than me yeah I'm
Ryan and I'm confident so shout out time
now there is a god this dude has been
yanking my [ __ ] nuts now about how I
keep forgetting to give him a shout-out
and I'm like hold on dude I'm going in
order of shoutouts he just keeps telling
me every day how I keep forgetting well
guess who's next on the list
Edgar Duran what's up mother [ __ ]
Edgar Duran Zagar this is finally your
shoutout enjoy your [ __ ] life I'm
messing with you still hanging out in
common I love you Jacob
leader he's the leader of all the Jacobs
what if that's a real last name how
badass is your family I am Jacob leader
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna listen to this guy
dude awesome Judah seems like Judah and
then with
some on the end of it I don't know if
you know this I'm a pretty big deal I'm
a pretty kind of a big you're awesome
just want to let you know that your name
I bet no one's told you that yet no one
we're the first people to call you that
mm-hmm that's what it's about here
original comedy yeah so you stay classy
San Diego